hey man to me kevin smith what i'm about
to show you here
is the jaws scene from chasing amy where
uh
ben affleck uh jason lee and
joey adams uh sit around as their
characters holden mcneil banky edwards
and alyssa jones
and discuss the scars they've received
from
oral sex this scene is
based on the scene in jaws one of my
favorite movies where the characters sit
around
on the boat and compare their scars we
took it a little further but if you look
rat face our production designer robert
ratface holtzman his choice for her name
not mine
uh ratface designed the booth where the
kids are sitting at meow mix
which i can't remember if it was
actually at meow mix or if we just shot
someplace else
but anyway the booth is designed
to look like the boat in
jaws like the windows and this is deep
cuts trivia
the lamp that's hanging it's the same
lamp from jaws rat face at least that's
what raphael's told me i never bothered
it's 24 years later i should probably
check the truth but
he was like i was able to order he's
from philly i was able to order the same
lamp from jaws we're going to have jaws
lamp hanging over you
in indians happy so uh it was
you know a delight for a jaws fan to see
that scene
play out and mimicked the way it was and
stuff
um ben has a moment that makes me laugh
still to this day i mean jason lee is
electric him and joey together are so
[ __ ] funny
but look for ben affleck when he does
the roy scheider
look for a scar that he wants to throw
in with and then he decides not to
because it's so weak sauce
um this obviously this scene was made by
a jaws fan
uh check it out man the chasing amy uh
scar scene aka the jaws scene
permanent injuries sure
you want to see something permanent
see that uh-huh i got that from nina
rollins
sophomore year i'm going down on her
right and out of nowhere her cat jumps
on her stomach and she does this big old
pelvic thrust
cracks my tooth and sends it down my
throat
i had to get a crown for the stub
i got that beat i got happy
junior year i'm going down on cynthia
slater in her dorm room after we went
club hopping
i'm totally drunk and in the middle of
it i fall asleep
right in her lap she got so mad she digs
her heel into my back
right there that's permanent
all right all right see this
that's the farthest i can move my neck
to the right again
sophomore year i'm going out with brandy
svinning
and for like six months i'm going down
on a right not a damn thing's happening
so one night i change your position or
vary my lapping speed
and suddenly it's a whole new
world she's moving around compulsing
breathing heavy and her legs are pressed
up against my ears so
tightly that i don't hear her father
come into the room he grabs my hair and
pulls me way back
hard
senior year spring formal i'm eating out
missy kurt in her brother's car
she's like laying across the back seat
and i'm half hanging out my knees on the
ground
she's flailing around and she she knocks
the parking brake off
the car starts rolling down the hill
and my left knee is cut up to [ __ ]
it's like a kitty scissors clasp
paper
cuz
[Laughter]
hey kids did you like that all these
movies are available on itunes or
netflix in some places
amazon and other places you can find
them they're available
patronize them if you will uh also if
you like this kind of stuff come on over
to that kevin smith club go to
thatkevinsmithclub.com
join up man i do wake and bake three
times a week where i wake up just smoke
weed with you all and stuff come to that
kevin smith club for more
video antics with kevin smith